what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some huge updates
about Jonathan Majors today we have a
bit of bad and good news in regards to
Jonathan Majors as he has been fired
from a couple of teams but deadline who
this report is coming from also claims
that they have heard from sources over
at Marvel Studios about what Jonathan
Majors current position is with them and
if you're looking for an overall update
on what is going on with his current
situation this is the video for you also
don't forget to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on everything including
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and so you
can enter our giveaway more about that
at the end now as I mentioned this
report is coming from deadline and it
starts off by stating that Jonathan
majors has been fired from two different
teams that he was currently a part of
and the first one is his management team
the report from deadline starts off by
stating exclusive talent manager
entertainment 360 has dropped Jonathan
Majors several sources tell us the
recent move by Majors is long time
manager comes three weeks after the
magazine dream star was arrested on
domestic violent charges in New York
City and here's where it gets kind of
interesting they continue to state
currently starring in Creed 3 and
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
majors's departure was due to issues
surrounding the actor's personal
Behavior we are informed Now personal
Behavior could simply mean the charges
that he is being dealt right now or they
could be talking about how he is
personally handling the situation right
now perhaps they aren't too pleased with
Jonathan majors and the way he's going
about things right now there could be a
number of different reasons of what this
means and we'll jump back to that in
just a second the article continues and
States Majors as representation problems
don't stop with entertainment 360. PR
firm the lead company also initiated a
break with the Avengers actor in the
last month and to top it all off they
State as a more minor element of this
majors and fashion house Valentino
mutually agreed that the actor would not
be attending this year's Met Gala as one
of its guests so not a great time right
now for Jonathan Majors he's been going
through a lot ever since he got arrested
which is understandable especially if
you consider he was arrested on domestic
violent charges but here's the real
interesting thing about this before we
dive into where he currently is at with
Marvel Studios Jonathan majors has not
been officially convicted of anything he
still has his court date coming up on
May 8th so Jonathan majors has yet to be
proven guilty so the two companies have
made their decision prior to an actual
verdict on the case which is incredibly
interesting especially if you go back to
what the article said in the beginning
where they stated that majors's
departure was due to issues surrounding
the actor's personal Behavior now in the
news about Jonathan Majors being
arrested came out there were some people
who used to work with Jonathan Majors
including one director and some old
College mates of his they came out and
stated that Jonathan Majors was kind of
a pain to work with in fact they
actually said he was a terror to work
with now at first a lot of people
weren't really sure what to think about
that because a lot of actors can be kind
of hard to work with especially when you
make it big time however that
information is pretty coincidental going
hand in hand with Jonathan Majors
parting ways with his companies due to
his personal behavior and it gets even
more interesting when you consider the
fact that Jonathan Major's lawyer came
out and stated that he was innocent and
in fact the victim of this entire
situation in fact when he was first
arrested his lawyer Priya Chaudhry came
out and stated Jonathan Majors is
completely innocent and is probably the
victim of an altercation with a woman he
knows we are quickly Gathering and
presenting evidence to the district
attorney with the expectation that all
charges will be dropped imminently then
she said evidence includes video footage
from the vehicle where this episode took
place witness testimony from the driver
and others who both saw and heard the
episode and most importantly two written
statements from the Woman recanting
these allegations now we would go on to
find that these written statements were
her texting Jonathan Majors after the
event happened and in these text
messages the woman said things like this
please let me know you're okay when you
get this they assured me that you won't
be charged they said they had to arrest
you as a protocol when they saw the
injuries on me and they knew we had a
fight I'm so angry that they did I'm so
sorry you're in this position I will
make sure nothing happens about this I
told them it was my fault for trying to
grab your phone so this makes it even
more interesting that these two
companies dropped him if you consider
the fact that his lawyer states that
they have evidence and they have shown
these text messages to the public
already that's very interesting and
there is probably some stuff that we
don't know of course that happens behind
the scenes perhaps this will come out
later on in the future however the big
thing that this article tells us is that
they have heard from their sources over
at Marvel Studios about what Marvel is
currently planning to do with Jonathan
majors and evidently as of right now
they aren't really planning to do
anything the article States majors has
already shot the second episode of
Marvel Disney pluses Loki in which he
reprises his Uber villain role of King
the Conqueror and won't go before the
cameras in Avengers the King Dynasty for
quite some time deadline hears there's
been zero conversations in the Marvel
Camp to drop Majors from the MCU now
this goes against what we have recently
heard which was an Insider report
stating that Marvel is looking for a
damson Idris type to play King the
Conqueror if Jonathan Majors is in fact
recast now deadline has a lot of
credibility but keep in mind deadline
states that they have heard this from a
source inside of Marvel they don't
actually State a name and typically if
it is somebody like Kevin feige or some
executive producer over at Marvel
Studios and they tell them this they
give them the okay to tell them this to
the public in which they State the name
of the source they say Kevin feige told
us this and they're not doing that here
which means the source is somebody
inside of Marvel who doesn't want their
name getting out and that's pretty much
what the other report was stating as
well they had a source at Marvel Studios
tell them that if they do indeed recast
Kang they're looking for a dampson I
just typed so yes both reports are
conflicting however both could be right
Marvel Studios might not have had any
official conversations about recasting
Jonathan Majors it seems like Marvel and
Disney are simply waiting to see what
the final verdict is for Jonathan Majors
especially since he says they have a lot
of evidence proving that he is innocent
and if he is indeed innocent then he
should not be fired from the MCU or
really anything else that he was
involved with however at the same time
Marvel Studios has to be smart they have
to be prepared for the worst case
scenario which would be them having to
recast Jonathan Majors as king it would
be foolish of them to not be prepared
especially since he's going to appear in
many different projects from now until
Avengers Secret Wars so I'm sure in
passing or casually over at Marvel
Studios they have talked about recasting
him a little bit more along on the lines
of so what exactly are we going to do if
this is the worst case scenario in which
obviously the answer would be well we
have to recast if we do get to that
worst case scenario but let's wait until
the official verdict comes out and let's
wait to hear what the judge has to say
and how he is convicted or not which is
honestly exactly what they should be
doing again it's very interesting that
these other two companies dropped him
without actually hearing the verdict of
his case especially when his lawyer is
claiming that he is the victim of this
and he is innocent and they have proof
that he's innocent and perhaps Jonathan
Majors simply got upset with these other
companies because they didn't fully back
him and believe that he was innocent in
this situation because most of the time
these companies especially a PR Company
tend to play defense a lot and try to
cover themselves so an argument between
them and Jonathan Majors could have
happened because they weren't entirely
in his Corner which is really hard for
both sides because he was arrested and
he was charged for multiple accounts of
assault that looks really really bad on
the surface so the companies were
probably panicking but if Jonathan
Majors is truly innocent then he knows
that and is pretty upset with the
companies for not fully supporting him
and that could have caused the rift
between him and these two companies and
that could be why they departed this
could also explain that personal
Behavior they are talking about he could
have been upset that they're not fully
supporting him and at this point in time
we really won't know anything until May
8th we'll have to see how it goes in
court and if any more evidence is
presented on behalf of Jonathan Majors
but for now the good news is it's
looking like Marvel Studios has not had
any official conversations about whether
or not to replace Jonathan Majors as
Kang in the MCU that's great news
because it's looking like they are truly
waiting to see what happens and if he
has proven innocent then nothing happens
he is going to remain Kang the Conqueror
and the MCU from now till Avengers
Secret Wars so let us know all of your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on the
latest news and so you can enter our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel and DC stuff
as well winner gets to choose we pick a
winner at the end of each month just
subscribe and leave a comment to enter
the giveaway you can always follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
foreign